[Musique]
réalisateur indépendant jérôme cioran
travaillent sur la production d'un moyen
métrage il réalise une scène de son
prochain film qui se déroule aux
archives départementales
c'est l'histoire d'une réunionnaise
kaffrine qui est qui atterrit sur qui
atterrit sur lille qui a perdu la
mémoire et elle va passer de lui en lieu
et on espère aller à payer par un brin
hommes et on espère qu'elles vont tous
ces lieux vont le faire retrouver la
mémoire
et elle vient aux archives nationales
pour en quelque sorte
retrouvez la voilà c'est la sinne la
culture globale qu donc c'est symbolique
les archives ça représente
ça représente c'est la concentration
voilà la concentration de la culture l
artiste polyvalent jérôme seront réalise
son projet de manière autonome le
département la compagne lui ouvrant les
portes des archives un lieu symbolique
pour ce film est pour les réunionnais
car ce site conserve la mémoire écrite
et iconographique de notre île c'est
départemental à la réunion comme dans
tous les départements français
elles ont pour mission de collecter de
conserver de communiquer valoriser les
archives publiques des institutions du
département donc les services de l'état
leur opérateur les archives du conseil
départemental et puis également les
archives privées qui nous sont confiées
pardon au dépôt ce moyen métrage d'une
quarantaine de minutes aura pu être
réalisée grâce au soutien de nombreux
bénévoles tous convaincu du talent de
jérôme cioran
[Musique]